Tim Cook just launched the product that
will Define his career one more thing
I'm excited to announce an entirely new
AR platform with a revolutionary new
product introducing Apple Vision Pro
Apple Vision Pro Vision Pro Vision Pro
Vision Pro there are already lots of
breakdowns analyzing the launch of the
Vision Pro but there's a bigger story
here a personal story it's the story of
Tim Cook the CEO of Apple and his
journey from small town in Alabama to
becoming one of the most important
figures in Tech today most people in
Tech focus on Founders and for good
reason building a company from nothing
is extremely difficult and should be
admired but being a non-founder CEO is a
unique challenge many people thought
replacing Steve Jobs would be impossible
but I would argue that Tim Cook's story
has become just as important to Apple
and Tech in general because it proves
that you can become an inspiring and
effective leader even if you're not the
person who's started the company cook
has had an incredible run as Apple's CEO
since he took over in 2011. he's doubled
the company's revenues and profits and
launched big new product lines with both
the Apple watch and airpods but he
hasn't had his iPhone moment don't get
me wrong the Apple watch and airpods are
great products that each make apple
about 10 billion dollars every year but
neither of them change the way we live
like the iPhone did The Vision Pro is
different I believe it has the potential
to be the first Apple product released
under Tim Cook's leadership that changes
the way we use computers and to
understand why you need to look at the
skills and strategies that Tim Cook has
cultivated over his career
Tim Cook isn't your average Tech Titan
he wasn't some crazy ambitious kid who
dropped out of Stanford to build a
startup instead he grew up in a Tiny
Town in Alabama his father worked at a
shipyard and his mom worked at a
pharmacy in 2014 cook became the first
CEO of a Fortune 500 company to publicly
come out as gay and I can't imagine what
it would have been like to grow up gay
in Alabama in the 1960s and 70s it must
have been incredibly difficult after
receiving his bachelor in science with a
major in industrial engineering from
Auburn University Cook didn't start a
company he went to work at IBM earning
an MBA and working his way up the
corporate ladder he was following a very
conventional some might even say boring
career path but he was also acquiring
really valuable business skills that
would end up paying huge dividends after
12 years at IBM cook wanted a change of
scenery so in 1994 he joined a company
called intelligent Electronics as the
Chief Operating Officer of their
computer reselling division he stuck it
out there until he moved to compact
computer in 1990 seven but he only
stayed in that job for six months
because just as he was getting settled
in he got a call from none other than
Steve Jobs today everyone views apple as
an Unstoppable Juggernaut that barely
ever makes mistakes but that wasn't
always the case because in 1998 it was
on the verge of collapse the 1990s had
been really bad for Apple they hired bad
CEOs released bad products do you
remember its games console the Pippin
they just couldn't make a dent in the
overwhelming dominance of Microsoft and
Intel the company wasn't just not
growing it was shrinking its revenues
declined drastically from 11 billion in
1995 to just 6 billion in 1998. after
Gail Emilio the CEO who oversaw the
company's worst ever quarter left the
company in July of 1997. jobs offered to
help Apple find their next leader and
fun fact job's role as interim CEO was
quickly shortened to I CEO making him
the first ever Apple product with that
famous prefix of course it didn't take
long for everyone to realize that the
perfect long-term CEO was the guy
already in the job with jobs back in the
hot seat he focused on writing the ship
with his Relentless focus on design and
usability but the company's
manufacturing and supply chain systems
were a total mess and jobs didn't know
how to fix them enter Tim Cook who by
then had 16 years of experience in
managing Supply chains in the Computing
industry in theory Cook's brief was
straightforward fix Apple's supply chain
and Logistics operations but in theory
climbing Everest is also very
straightforward still cook dove into his
new role with the hard work and
methodical execution that were becoming
his trademark he immediately realized
that the beauty of Apple's products
wouldn't count for much if they weren't
delivered on time and at competitive
prices so he put effective Supply Chain
management at the core of Apple's
business one of the first things he did
was cut the number of Apple's key
suppliers by 75 percent and negotiate
tighter relationships with the survivors
he even request tested that some of them
move closer to Apple Affiliated
factories to further reduce costs how is
he able to make these kinds of Demands
wasn't Apple struggling it's true they
were but cook understood that despite
Apple's problems the company's High
sales and deep cash reserves still made
them an attractive Prospect for contract
suppliers who craved stable cash flows
Above All Else cook used that to
negotiate lucrative long-term contracts
with suppliers that gave Apple lots of
control over the manufacturing process
Beyond overhauling Apple Supply chains
cook also had several flashes of
brilliant Insight that helped him win
the trust of Steve Jobs he realized that
lots of Apple's new products like the
iPod Nano needed a steady supply of
flash memory but flash memory was in
short supply at that time so cook
gambled he called up flash memory
manufacturers and pre-bought more than a
billion dollars worth of flash memory
effectively keeping the competition at
Bay for more than five years the
manufacturer fracturers love the stable
cash flows Apple's competitors hated
being blocked from accessing flash
memory and Steve Jobs loved that his
supply chain guy had so cleverly screwed
over the competition cook found other
ways to optimize too he noticed that
Apple would be caught in a crunch right
around the holiday season customers
wanted to make sure that their new Apple
devices would arrive in time for
Christmas but that's when shipping
routes were the most congested because
of people flying home so cook called up
all the Air Freight companies that could
help Apple fly products to their
destinations and pre-bought tons of
capacity to make sure Apple could
deliver everything on time there's so
many stories like this but cook still
wasn't done there were other problems to
solve like Apple's bloated inventories
cook realized that Apple's inventory was
losing between one to two percent of
value every week so he went lean
streamlining manufacturing to the point
where Apple products were often shipped
directly from factories in places like
Taiwan to Consumers long time Apple
veterans were prized by the priority
that the company suddenly placed on
Supply Chain management but what they
probably didn't realize was that cooks
work to improve Apple's supply chain was
critical to building the company's
reputation for quality and its ability
to differentiate its products from its
competitors cook and jobs complemented
each other perfectly jobs was the
Maverick Visionary and cook was the by
the Numbers guy who was always looking
for marginal gains in a way they were
different expressions of the same
philosophy but then in 2011 tragedy
struck Steve Jobs was diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer
he resigned as CEO and handed over the
reins to the man who had helped save
Apple six weeks later Jobs died
and Tim Cook lost his friend and mentor
thank you
he had incredibly large shoes to fill
jobs had been an Unstoppable Force while
at Apple he'd started the company in
1976 and taken it from nothing to one of
the world's most important companies
lots of people thought he was
Irreplaceable they assumed that jobs was
the only one who could create the real
Innovation that Apple was known for Tim
Cook would soon prove that wrong but in
an unexpected way but before he did he
had to make some changes he wanted to
avoid the inevitable political
infighting that crops up in any large
organization Scott Forstall was the
first executive to go he'd been in
charge of the disastrous Apple Maps
launch and although he technically
resigned most people agree he was
dismissed in order to create more Unity
within the executive team John bralett
who was the senior VP of retail was
fired six months after he joined the
company skepticism about Cook's
performance lingered for many years in
2016 some analysts even compared him to
former Microsoft CEO Steve Ballmer
claiming that Innovation had died down
since he replace jobs similar to when
Balmer replaced Bill Gates but the cook
era proved to be a dramatic success he
doubled both revenue and profit in less
than 10 years and took Apple's market
cap from 348 billion to 1.9 trillion
this was a great Testament to Cook's
ability to optimize and grow the
business Apple was running like a
well-oiled machine yearly upgrades to
the iPhone meant the company was
swimming in cash but the iPhone was a
Steve Jobs product not a Tim Cook
product to leave his Mark in the history
books cook would have to deliver
something entirely new and this is where
we get to the Apple Vision Pro
cook has been working on this thing for
basically a decade at this point we just
didn't hear much about it but if you go
back far enough and look hard enough you
can find some hints that explain what's
going on today firstly Apple has been
experimenting with headsets for decades
there's actually an old Apple demo from
1987 where they showed off a prototype
and Tim Cook was answering questions
from interviews about the future of
wearable computers as far back as 2013.
I'm interested in a great product I wear
glasses because I have to I don't know a
lot of people that wear them that don't
have to there are even photos of him
wearing Google Glass as is so often the
case to find the real details you have
to look at the numbers in 2015 a
financial analyst was researching apple
and discovered that they were hiring a
small team to explore augmented and
virtual reality around this time Apple
actually patented a VR headset for the
iPhone cook also started acquiring
companies with strengths and the same
technology that the Vision Pro will have
his first purchase was a company called
Prime sense they had developed a
technology that could track body
movements specifically to let people
control computers without an input
device like a controller or keyboard
they also bought metau a company that
was focused on creating augmented
reality scenarios the technology was
still at an early stage but cook
realized that it could have an impact if
it was integrated into the bigger
project Apple was working on he also
acquired not one but three different
companies focused on facial capture
technology this helped Apple in the
short term by letting face ID unlock
your phone and it also powered the
animoji system but in the long term it
would prove critical to the user
interface Apple wanted to build for the
Vision Pro these Acquisitions marked a
bit of a change in strategy for Apple
Steve Jobs had never been focused on
buying companies he preferred to
innovate from within but cook recognized
that he needed to put a bunch of
different pieces of new technology
together in order to make something that
would actually work Apple's whole
strategy can be summed up with one word
integration when people talk about the
Apple ecosystem they're usually talking
about how well Apple products sync
together or even just how nice they look
side by side but for me the ecosystem is
even better than that the reason that
the iPhone works so well and has been
such a success is that Apple controls
everything involved in making it work
from the design to The Branding to the
manufacturing and the user experience
they control the operating system and
can make regular updates to iOS whenever
they want they write lots of the apps
that run on the iPhone and thanks to Tim
Cook they have an incredibly tight grip
on the supply chain that manufactures
the actual devices most recently cook
has gotten Apple into developing their
own chips the M1 unlocked remarkable
performance gains for their desktop and
laptop computers but that chip is also
key to making the Apple Vision Pro
headset work effectively this is why in
hindsight it makes sense for a great
operations leader like cook to take over
from Steve Jobs jobs drove the highest
imaginable standards of design quality
and user experience but cook has been
able to maintain that Focus while also
building one of the world's most tightly
integrated supply chain operations and
it actually makes a lot of sense that
the guy in charge of the company's
overall vision is the one with an
amazing eye for logistical details the
last decade of Apple's success has been
defined by Apple doing things that other
manufacturers just can't it's all
because of Apple's integrated approach
the Apple Vision Pro is the perfect
example of this integrated approach
paying off in a big way not only does
the headset use an M2 Chip but it has a
second custom chip from Apple called the
R1 and this chip is arguably even more
important than the M2 here's why if you
paid close attention to Tim Cook when he
launched the headset you might have
noticed that he didn't spend a lot of
time talking about virtual or augmented
reality and there's a good reason for
that the Apple Vision Pro headset
doesn't fit neatly into either of those
categories it's basically both and
that's one of the best things about it
technically it's a virtual reality
headset you can't see the outside world
through the lenses that's different than
previous attempts at augmented reality
like Microsoft's hololens and the magic
leap if the headset is off or doesn't
have power you won't see anything the
screen will just be black but when you
turn it on you can see the outside world
and everyone who's tried the headset
can't stop talking about how realistic
the world looks through the headset so
what's going on well the Vision Pro is
technically reprojecting the outside
world onto the displays inside the
headset the camera is on the outside of
the headset are constantly recording the
world and streaming those images to the
screen that you're looking at through
the Vision Pro this is not easy to get
right there's even a slight delay
between when an image is captured and
when it's displayed in the headset
you'll notice and it'll start to break
the illusion but Apple has gotten lag
time down to just a few milliseconds
which puts the Vision Pro in a different
League from the other headsets that are
currently on the market the metaquest
has a similar feature where video is
passed through to the headset but it has
way lower resolution and often lags too
much to be really usable in the same way
and augmented reality devices like the
hololens and Magic leap have always been
plagued by narrow fields of you
basically everything looked pretty good
in the center of your vision but as soon
as anything left that very narrow area
it would Disappear Completely these
problems can be solved by something
called reprojection when you're trying
to do Augmented Reality by projecting an
image onto glass that you're actually
looking through there are tons of
limitations Beyond just the small field
of view you can't project something dark
on top of something bright just try
watching Game of Thrones especially the
Battle of Winterfell on a projector in a
brightly lit room it defies the laws of
physics but reprojection allows Apple to
control everything you're seeing so when
a dinosaur comes walking through your
wall it can blend seamlessly into the
surrounding environment because
everything you're seeing is actually
being shown on the headset's display
this convergence of AR and VR was
actually predicted by Palmer lucky the
founder of oculus and one of the
earliest VR Pioneers two years he
tweeted that the future of AR is
reprojection not Optical transparency
and he actually mentioned this to me
when I interviewed him a few months ago
AR and VR basically the same thing it's
all going to converge to basically the
same idea as just how much what you see
is real versus how much what you see is
virtual the content will define whether
it's arvr not not the hardware devices I
believe I think it's all reprojected but
reprojection is only possible at the
level of fidelity that the Vision Pro
will offer because of the hard work Tim
Cook did to improve Apple's Supply
Chains It's like he planted all these
seeds years ago then waited to see how
headset technology would evolve and The
Vision Pro is the flower that eventually
blossomed but the Vision Pro is more
than a Triumph of planning and patience
it's a response to the people who said
that Apple could never be an Innovative
company again under Tim Cook Apple has
always been known for creating
delightful user experiences and there
was a real risk that the company would
lose some of this Focus after the Steve
Jobs era ended but it's important to
remember that Apple has launched some
amazing and subtle user interactions in
her cook that everyone loves consider
the two-factor authentication autofill
feature every time someone posts this on
Twitter it goes massively viral because
of how much everyone loves it and for
good reason those codes are annoying and
apple came up with an interesting way to
make life easier this feature launched
while Tim Cook was CEO and I think it
gives us insight into how apple is
planning to solve some of the more
mundane problems that have plagued VR
over the years the meta Quest is a cool
headset I think I've owned four
different versions at this point but
somehow I have more passwords than
headsets I have a Facebook password an
Instagram password an Oculus password a
meta password that's supposed to work
across all of them but then the quest
also has a passcode for making purchases
in the store and a pin you can draw to
unlock the device it's a mess and it
makes using the headset extremely
frustrating password managers don't work
in VR and taking the headset on and off
to log in totally kills the experience
you know Tim Cook won't let Apple launch
a headset with cumbersome setup process
the headset is going to use facial
scanning technology that it acquired
years ago to log you in automatically
you probably won't ever need to enter a
password this might sound like a minor
detail but it's really important lots of
people have bought VR headsets only to
let them sit in the closet and collect
dust because they were too annoying to
use regularly Tim Cook is clearly aiming
to eliminate every possible flaw with
this product and he needs to because
this thing costs thirty five hundred
dollars now that's obviously crazy
expensive but and you might disagree
with me here I think it's actually not
that crazy in the context of other Apple
products after all the Apple Pro display
xdr sells for six thousand dollars and
plenty of people buy those for
professional work and if the Apple
Vision Pro can replace a multi-monitor
setup or an expensive big screen TV the
price suddenly doesn't seem all that
unreasonable Apple's pricing strategy
has actually evolved a lot during the
Tim Cook era remember he was CEO when
Apple launched the ten thousand dollar
gold Apple watch Edition he was also in
charge when Apple dropped the Mac Pro
that can cost almost sixty thousand
dollars now both of those products were
ridiculously expensive but Tim Cook
realized that there are plenty of people
who will pay those prices for Apple
products the same is true for the Vision
Pro the clue is in the name clearly
Apple thinks of this as a pro device and
they left the door open to creating a
cheaper non-pro version in the future
but with all the tech in this thing I
wouldn't count on being able to pick up
a headset for under a thousand dollars
anytime soon Cook's pricing strategy
here is worth examining in some more
detail Apple originally estimated that
they'd sell around 1 million Vision Pro
headsets next year although since then
it looks like they might have to
downgrade that to 150 000. by all
accounts meta has sold about 20 million
Quest headsets but you can get one of
those for under 300 bucks The Vision Pro
will cost more than 10 times as much
even if Apple only reaches the smaller
Target that's still a decent chunk of
the lifetime revenues of the quest and
if they get anywhere near their original
sales Target then they'll wind up making
about half of what the quest has ever
made just in one year apple is also able
to charge so much for its products
because people trust them to deliver
good quality and great design it's the
dividend of years of hard work the
pricing strategy reminds me of Tesla's
in the early days the Tesla Roadster
cost a hundred thousand dollars when it
launched way more than the average
American spends on a car but it solved
all the key problems because it proved
that electric cars could work while
being cool most importantly the Roadster
perfectly primed consumers for the model
S and model 3 which brought down the
price to a point more people could
afford but where Elon Musk had a very
clear idea of where Tesla was going it
seems like Tim Cook isn't entirely sure
what the future will look like when it
comes to the Apple Vision Pro the use
case for electric cars is obvious they
replace cars powered by internal
combustion engines but they still do the
exact same thing but there are a bunch
of different things you could use the
Vision Pro for and no one really knows
what will be the most valuable every VR
fan wants there to be a killer gaming
app that's like ninety percent of the
metaverse pitch but Tim Cook didn't say
the word metaverse even once during his
presentation realistically making
immersive AAA standard games for
headsets is going to take years not many
people will have these headsets and it
simply takes years to make a great game
just ask Rockstar Games when GTA 6 is
coming I'm sure that there will be some
games developed for the headset pretty
quickly but in the meantime there are
other forms of entertainment that will
be easier to Port over 3D movies are an
obvious choice Avatar smashed box office
records but if you missed it in theaters
you'll never really get that immersive
3D experience at home watching avatar on
a vision headset could actually deliver
a top tier experience the same goes for
sports content one of the demos that
reviewers praised the most was sitting
Courtside in an NBA game watching
basketball games with Vision Pro is a
promising use case because the games are
already happening with video games you
have to solve all these difficult user
interaction issues and most importantly
actually come up with a good idea for a
game but basketball is already
entertaining or what about soccer Apple
has already signed a broadcasting deal
with major league soccer and I bet
millions of people would love to see
Lionel Messi up close like that this is
by no means a solved problem but Tim
Cook and his team seem to have come up
with some really Creative Solutions
actually capturing 3D video in a format
that feels realistic in The Vision Pro
required building a custom camera rig
the team also created the Apple
immersive video format to standardize
this type of content getting content
producers to start recording content in
this format would be a big challenge for
most companies but Tim Cook has been
building relationships through Apple TV
and their streaming service for years I
mean Bob Iger the CEO of Disney was on
stage during this announcement user
generated content is shaping up to be
another major use case for The Vision
Pro when you're wearing the headset you
can record video in 3D and then play it
back later but this is obviously awkward
because you have to be wearing the
headset in order to record the footage
which is a guaranteed way to get some
weird looks but Apple will probably add
3D video recording to a future version
of the iPhone which would basically fix
that problem since people are constantly
recording videos with their phones today
even if you can record 3D video with
your iPhone it's going to be a while
until wearing a headset doesn't look
awkward Tim Cook never actually put the
headset on during the presentation and
neither did any of the other Apple execs
who were there these headsets are going
to be a little weird to get used to and
so will those eyes on the outside of the
headset ultimately these are mostly
technical problems and Apple has proven
that they excel at solving problems like
these but there's deeper critique that
cook will have to contend with over the
next few years whenever new technology
is introduced there are always questions
and debates about how it will change
society just look at what's going on
with AI right now as the internet and
smartphones have proliferated we've all
spent more time basically immersed in
Virtual Worlds there's a real risk of
Technology increasing loneliness and
turning our society inward we need to
find a healthy balance between
technology and the real world and
frankly big tech companies have to be
part of the discussion because they're
the ones creating the immersive worlds
and the devices to access them there's
actually a fascinating cautionary tale
from almost 90 years ago it's a science
fiction short story called Pygmalion
spectacles first published in 1935 it's
a story about a man named Dan Burke who
receives a revolutionary virtual reality
device called Pygmalion spectacles
despite warnings from his friends and
family Burke becomes obsessed with the
digital world ultimately Dan decides to
leave his physical body and permanently
live in the virtual world with Angel
these cautionary tales have been retold
again and again there are elements of
this in Minority Report there's an
entire Black Mirror episode about the
consequences of this technology and
obviously Ready Player One explores this
idea in depth an even more extreme
version is the philosophical thought
experiment called the brain in a vat the
basic scenario involves a mad scientist
machine or other entity who removes a
person's brain from their body puts it
in a vat of life-sustaining liquid and
connects it to a supercomputer the
supercomputer provides it with
electrical impulses which are identical
to the ones normally received by the
brain it can even be used to mimic
feelings of intense happiness but of
course you're not really happy you're
just a brain in a vat these are real
problems worth taking seriously lots of
people feel disconnected and have
unhealthy experiences in Virtual
environments but I'm actually optimistic
about how all of this will play out
first wearable headsets will be a
novelty for quite some time the battery
life is limited most people just won't
want to wear this 24 7 because of the
inconvenience and stigma and even once
these headsets become commonplace I
think they will mostly replace other
screen time instead of staring at a
computer screen you'll wear a headset
and that doesn't seem all that dystopian
as long as you're still going outside
and connecting with people in the real
world but this could definitely become
addictive there is a real risk that
people get sucked into Virtual Worlds
especially as AI gets better and better
Virtual Worlds will often look better to
people than the real world there's a
countervailing force though Humanity
we've always been incredibly Dynamic and
resilient whenever something becomes
universally accepted there are always
people who resist and go a different
direction lots of people today refuse to
use social media or carry dumb phones
instead of smartphones as long as the
most important moments of our life are
experienced in the real world it'll take
precedence over the virtual world
clearly there will be problems that
we'll need to work through and adapt to
but I'm really optimistic about the
benefits of this new technology and part
of the reason why I'm optimistic is
because Tim Cook has now emerged as one
of the leaders in this space I trust his
ability to Grapple with these tough
decisions better than most even though
he runs a massive computer company he
loves the outdoors he goes hiking
regularly and constantly finds ways to
unplug basically he knows how to touch
grass most importantly though cook is
deeply empathetic in 2009 after Steve
Jobs was diagnosed with cancer cook
offered to donate a portion of his liver
to jobs in Hope of extending his life
the two of them shared a rare blood type
but jobs rejected his offer cook said it
was one of the only times jobs actually
yelled at him this is just one anecdote
but I think it's really revealing of the
type of person Tim Cook is he's deeply
human at his core and I think he'll be a
good Steward of this technology as our
world gets more and more complex now
even though Tim Cook seems poised for
success with this product launch he's
been facing big challenges with Apple's
supply chain in China and to understand
why you have to watch this video next
thanks a lot